one of the most exciting aspects of the
lead up to Deadpool 2 was the arrival of
a comic book superhero team x-force a
harder-edged and more militant take on
good guy mutant alliances like the x-men
you guys look amazing
no doubt you look amazing two fans
speculated on what Terry Cruz's bedlam
lewiston's shatter star and Bill
skarsgård zeitgeist would bring to the
fight in the Deadpool sequel and where
things might all be ultimately going
with the x-force team up movie the
possibilities seemed endless and then
everybody died really the sequence in
which most of the members of Deadpool's
new team or die comically during a
parachute jump just minutes after being
introduced is one of the funniest things
to happen in all of Deadpool 2 and a lot
of that has to do with how totally
unexpected it was this was no accident
it took a whole lot of work to keep that
sequence a surprise and that bewildered
reactions a movie earned from audiences
everywhere
is actually the entire reason the movies
creative team set out to do it director
david leitch said that he was obsessed
with the idea of tricking audiences into
thinking Deadpool 2 would feature some
actual substantial team-up action saying
we all loved it it's such a great
irreverent Deadpool world gag that you
can't not do it when Reynolds couldn't
have agreed more in order to make a
great rated-r comic book omelet you
gotta break some eggs as revealed in the
special features for Deadpool 2's home
media release the filmmakers went to
dramatic lens to keep x-force's fate
top-secret in many instances not even
the crew of the movie knew exactly what
they were shooting at any given moment
with exact details being kept on a
strict need-to-know basis according to
Wernick many of the film sides or unset
script pages came in the color red
making them harder to photocopy they
were also frequently full of reductive
information and all turned in and
shredded at the end of every day it's
like some spy man the actors who played
the x-force members were unable to see
much if any information about their
parts during the filmmaking process they
were also discouraged from sharing what
info they did learn with friends and
family even though agents didn't know
what they were doing David called me and
said can't tell anybody
even tell your representation they know
I'm in the movie but they don't know
what I'm doing Rob Delaney who played
the gung-ho but useless exports member
Peter was also kept in the dark about
many aspects of his role despite the
fact that he's not playing a character
from the comic books at all i catfished
here the production even worked to film
scenes for the movies promotional
materials that they knew would never
make it to a final cut all for the
purpose of further luring audiences him
for the team-up fake-out deadpool -
co-writer Rhett Reese told Entertainment
Weekly what the actors were very
gracious about doing was shooting
footage they knew was not actually going
to be in the movie so he could trick
people into thinking they're in the
movie longer than they actually were if
you watch trailers and commercials
you'll watch bedlam and Shatter star out
on the street kicking people's ass it
was all done with the knowledge it
wouldn't be in the movie it sounds like
the filmmakers took some ridiculously
complicated steps to keep the plot and
the wraps but then again that is the
Deadpool way
[Music]